- Hi Kelly, my name is Ashley.
I'm a mom of two.
And last year I didn't
explain the whole Santa thing
to my daughter who was three.
So Christmas morning she wakes up under
the tree there's all
these Christmas presents,
and she's like, where these come from?
And I told her "this man
comes down the chimney,
and he leaves presents for you".
And she's like, "Mom it's Corona virus,
I don't know if he's vaccinated,
I don't think people
can come into our homes right now."
- And you just said a man
comes down your chimney.
- Well, he is a healthcare worker.
(crowd laughs)
Yip, he was vaccinated last Christmas.
- She's not really a fan of
Santa's and or Christmas.
I'm gonna try again this year.
So my question is how do you
explain Santa to your children?
- [Kelly] Wow
- [Zooey] I have one.
- This is tricky for me.
- I have one.
You say Santa left presents,
he left them on the balcony,
which is what he did for us.
I don't know if you
guys put the request in,
but like outdoor.
- We're not connected.
(crowd laughs)
- [Zooey] You just put
the requests in to Santa.
You say "Santa, I want
them on my balcony".
- [Kelly] Oh yeah, the balcony.
What do you do?
- Well, not that
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Once again.
- I'm learning a lot right now,
you're really leading me to
better decisions overall,
I really need to get my admin together.
But I'll tell ya I'm
impressed that your little one
had even the aware with all
to think all those things,
and I think they have
a bright future in HR.
If I was gonna say.
- [Zooey] Yeah.
- [Kristin] It sounds like
they're really smart rule followers.
- Yeah or like the legal professions.
- Yeah legal, maybe
like a senior inspector
- 100%, totally.
- Yes.
(Kelly laughs).
- Like a comptroller or something.
- Oh my gosh, the future is
bright for your santa goer.
- [Zooey] Yeah.
- [Kelly] What do you
do? Do you say anything?
- [Jen] Well, the hardest
thing to explain to my kids
was why there's a Santa at every mall.
And I'm like well, Santa's magical.
There's one Santa, but
he has all these helpers.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And if I had the resources
and that kind of money,
I'd be really magical too.
(crowd laughs)
- If I had all (indistinguishable)
(crowd applauds)
- Thank you so much, Ashley.
(audiences applauds continue)
- [Kristin] Great question.
- Complicated stuff.
- [Kelly] Complicated.